what's next for britney spears after she
dropped the hammer on her father
asking him to be charged with abuse
welcome everyone to the bahama resort
i'm just really happy to have bellamy
young here
with us again yeah you know kevin he was
mean to you last time we were both
terrified
we were screaming at the same decibel
yes we were
listen we have so much fun ahead with
bellamy but first britney's feeling a
lot better now after her tear-filled
triumph in court
brittany celebrated her legal victory
with cartwheels and horseback riding
and for the first time used the free
britney hashtag on instagram
in court it was britney versus her
father we will be moving promptly
and aggressively for his removal the
singer testified
my dad needs to be removed today it's
bad
she claimed the conservatorship denied
her basic things like
coffee her driver's license and hair
vitamins
but the attorney for her dad fired back
saying jamie no longer has control of
her day-to-day life
she also claimed britney made a lot of
misstatements
the attorney for jody montgomery
britney's other conservator
said i don't think it's a secret that
we're dealing with someone with mental
illness
brittany says she does not want a
psychiatric evaluation
fred also doubled down on wanting her
dad charged with conservator abuse
i think it would probably be a good idea
if the judge did authorize an
investigation
legal expert rachel stockman says there
are a lot of unknowns
the question here is there a legal claim
i do
think that there is more that needs to
come out about what exactly
happened the last time i saw her uh it
broke my heart
backstreet boy aj mclean who is
neighbors with brittany told andy cohen
radio
he recently bumped into brit at a
cupcake store she looked right at me
and i was like hey it's aj and
she just kind of had this glass face
like she just didn't know who was there
it took her a minute we hugged and we
talked for a brief moment
but i could just see that you know this
this wasn't
her so again free britney that's my
whole thing man